welcome to the man of recaps this is
house of the dragon episode one welcome
back to westeros yes it's the first game
of thrones new series after its less
than stellar final season or about 200
years before the events of game of
thrones so this is multiple generations
back by the time of game of thrones
dragons were thought to be extinct until
daenerys targaryen hatched her three new
ones but in house of the dragon were at
the peak of targaryen power in westeros
and they got like 10 fully grown dragons
under their control let's meet our first
main character the young princess
rhaenyra targaryen she's a cool
confident dragon rider just like
daenerys was and so far seems like a
pretty good person her bodyguard is this
buffald kingsguard guy and her best
friend in handmaiden is alison hightower
and more on her later the king is her
father viserys targaryen it's a time of
peace and prosperity everything's real
chill the big problem is the line of
succession cyroneera is his only child
he doesn't have a son and there's
precedent right now to skip over girls
the king right before him also had no
living sons and they held a great
council to decide who should be next and
the realm decided they didn't want a
queen so they skipped over the cousin
rainey targaryen and went for viserys
instead so now by president they would
skip over renera and go for her uncle
damon targaryen damon is a bold ass dude
who's an accomplished warrior and has
just recently taken control of the city
watch the gold cloaks and he is real
tough on crime this night they round up
a bunch of people and meet out
punishment's willy-nilly and you know i
didn't see any lawyers present so it's
unclear if these people were criminals
or just whichever peasants happen to be
in the streets the king viserys isn't
worried he's like hey that's just damon
b and damon but the hand of the king
remember that's the right hand man is
otto hightower and he does not like
damon another big player on the small
council is coreless valerian we don't
really get to know him yet but he is
married to rhaenys targaryen the old
cousin that was passed over the queen
who never was now this whole succession
problem might not be a problem because
the king's wife is pregnant and if she
gives birth to a son well problem solved
so in honor of the potential new heir
the king is hosting a grand tournament
and yes it's awesome they're doing some
hardcore jousting wham yeah damon
targaryen is obviously a favorite and he
wears super sick dragon armor yeah
they've kicked the costumes up a notch
in the show but there's a newcomer sir
kristen cole who's really no big deal
he's like a lowborn guy but he's kicking
ass here makes a name for himself and
goes against damon in the finals and
it's an epic joust in an epic fight and
in the end this kristen cole straight up
wins but during this journey the queen
goes into labor and it's not good it's
that awful situation where the only way
to save the child is to operate which
would kill the mother and it gets worse
because the beautiful baby boy doesn't
make it either sad times for the
targaryens they have a big funeral which
does involve by the way dragon fire pyre
okay that's cool the king is heartbroken
so the hand auto hightower brings in his
daughter alice and hightower who is
rinera's handmaiden and best friend now
the hand otto hightower mostly seems
like a good guy but now he's like hey
daughter why don't you go comfort the
old king bro are you pimping out your
daughter to your boss to like get more
power what are you doing allison we
don't know well yet she seems like just
a nice person but she's the dutiful
daughter goes to visit the king just to
read him a book and comfort him but you
know that's how it starts now while the
king is sad damon targaryen is having a
party he's rented out a brothel for all
his best friends cause he's definitely
gonna be king now and allegedly he gave
a speech where he referred to his poor
deceased nephew as heir for a day which
is you know in real bad taste so the
king calls his brother in like bro you
were way out of line and this was the
thing that pushed him over the edge he
names damon not his heir so damon
targaryen is going home apparently he
has a wife in the veil but he says he
doesn't like her instead he's gonna take
his mistress with him and by the way
he's got a sick ride he's got a dragon
and so the time has finally come king
viserys admits he's not going to have a
son he names his daughter renera heir to
the iron throne now rhaenyra didn't
particularly want it she was happy to
fly around on dragons without
responsibility but she does seem smart
and capable and just and nice so
hopefully she'll make a great queen but
while ronira might make a great queen
and all the lords here at king's landing
pleasure they're filthy there's a lot of
other lords out there who might prefer a
male heir like damon and so the stage is
set for a potentially messy succession
and that's where house of the dragon
episode 1 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]